[Music]
get 12 weeks of the spectator
in print and online for just 12 pounds
and we'll give you a 20 pound amazon
gift voucher
absolutely free go to spectator dot co
dot uk
forward slash voucher
welcome to spectator out loud i'm fraser
nelson
every week we ask some of our writers to
read out their articles from the
magazine and this week we have freddie
gray writing about donald trump's
reelection campaign
we have emma byrne writing about her
extraordinary situation
being caught up in the new cladding
scandal and finally larry prendergast in
the pitfalls of floral masks
first freddie gray keep america great
is president donald trump's 2020
re-election slogan
and it sounds off the phrase doesn't
have the same ring as make america great
again
the mantra that trump pinched from
reagan and repeated to victory in 2016.
as an acronym kag is uglier than magga
the words particularly jar when
america's cities are burning
homicide rates are spiking almost 180
000 americans have died
of or with covid and the country is
reeling from the largest economic shock
of all time
you call that great then again
2020 is an even crazier year than 2016
and the maddest news is that donald
trump might be about to defy the odds
again
and win he remains much
loathed divisive behind in the polls
but he's suddenly running a much better
campaign than his opponent
the democratic nominee joe biden and
it's beginning to show
compare and contrast the two big party
conventions we've just witnessed
this week the republican party had its
quadrennial nomination fest
and it felt much more coherent than the
event that democrats put on last week
thanks to kovid both conventions have
been conducted online
which gives them an unreal quality yet
team trump's video presentation has been
slicker
and simpler than biden's despite or
maybe because of
the fact that the democrats had had the
might of hollywood in the entertainment
industry behind them
perhaps it is the benefit of going
second
trump show is still weird as hell of
course
on tuesday the republicans had to pull
one of the speakers
an angel mom called mary anne mendoza
after she posted links to an online
conspiracy theory that suggested the
rothschild family
is trying to enslave the world do
yourself a favor and read this thread
she tweeted
then later claimed she hadn't read it
herself
that whiff of anti-semitism was offset
by mike pompeo the secretary of state
who arguably breached diplomatic
protocols by delivering his convention
address from the rooftop of the king
david hotel
in jerusalem israel after pompeo
melania trump the first lady came over
well as she praised her husband and
talked about protecting children from
social media and addiction
many americans may be wondering though
why they had to hear speeches from not
one
not two but six members of the
president's family
on monday kimberly guilfoyle the former
tv presenter
sounded possessed as she howled almost
orgasmically that the best is yet
to come team trump called that passion
everybody else knows that the reason she
is on the campaign is because she is
donald jr's girlfriend
it's a land of opportunity yet that
sordid freakiness is the key to trump's
success
five long years after he descended that
shiny moving staircase in the trump
tower to launch his presidential bid
he still has the power to horrify the
media and fascinate people
his great talent as a campaigner is that
while much of the world continues to
shriek and gaurp at the trump circus
the president and his talking heads are
able to speak directly to american
voters about the issues that most
concern
again and again this week family trump
touched on the economy
china restoring law and order and free
speech
the democrats by contrast use their
convention to fulminate against trump's
character
and structural racism many americans
agree that trump is awful
they fear that under his divisive
leadership the country is falling apart
but voters are more immediately afraid
about their jobs
and poll after poll suggests that voters
trust trump
more than biden to fix the economy
americans will also have noticed that
after an enormous drop
at the peak of the coveted crisis
employment is rebounding
the greatest economy the world has ever
seen as trump likes to call it
the one he claims to have built entirely
through his unique brilliance
is roaring back in may and june
trump struggled to identify biden's weak
points his campaign mocked the
democratic nominee for being mentally
frail
perhaps not realizing that a huge
percentage of the american electorate is
over 65
and doesn't respond well to that talk
but team trump has now adapted its
sleepy joe rhetoric
their latest campaign videos say that
the radical left
has taken over joe biden as if the poor
old boy had been impregnated
by a malevolent alien
judging by the recent tightening in the
polls that message is getting through to
the public
trump's critics are fond of saying that
the president is only interested in
campaigning
he doesn't care about governing it's a
fair point
yet people forget what a canyon creative
campaigner he can be
he always seems to find a way to win
biden lacks trump's originality
the democratic candidate surprised many
observers last week by giving a fairly
fluent nomination speech
he'd looked so catalytic recently that
most viewers were impressed that his
ability to read quite well from a
teleprompter
that's not exactly a high bar given that
he wants to lead the free world
and the speech turns out to have been
shockingly similar to his vice
presidential nomination speech in 2008
as a viral mash-up video of the two
addresses shows
biden only mentioned china once family
trump on the other hand this week called
covert 19 the chinese virus at every
opportunity
such talk offends delicate liberals but
plays well in america's rust belt
where workers have lost out to chinese
labor
seen relatives overdose on chinese-made
opioids
and have now had their hopes ripped away
from them again by a disease that
originated in china
not so long ago team biden seemed to
understand the importance of sounding
tough against beijing
in april a biden advertisement claimed
that trump had rolled over for the
chinese as coronavirus spread around the
world
but some democrats called that line of
attack cynophobic
and accused biden of trying to out-trump
trump the horror
that manic political correctness and
national self-loathing
are the democratic party's most
crippling flaws
biden and co try to talk about american
exceptionalism but they always end up
talking about racism
trump republicans by contrast are
increasingly skillful
at presenting themselves as optimistic
and open-hearted patriots
on monday night as lefty twitter users
kept snickering over
guilfoyle's undulations millions tuned
into the speech of the black senator tim
scott
who said that he was living his mother's
american dream
and believed that the next american
century can be better than the last
another speaker that night was maximum
alvarez a cuban immigrant
who said if i gave away everything i
have today
it would not equal one percent of what i
was given when i came to this great
country of ours
the gift of freedom americans have
always lapped that stuff up
and the stars and stripes schmaltz fits
the keep america great theme
yet both parties realize that the times
they are apocalyptic
and that means they must discuss the
darkness as much as the light
team biden talks about the end of
democracy if trump isn't removed from
office
team trump says that the radical left is
destroying western civilization
and america will be finished if the
democrats take over this time
the agitators in several american cities
seem hell-bent on proving the
republicans right
on sunday night a violent black lives
matter protest erupted in response to
yet another disturbing online video of a
police shooting
this time in kenosha wisconsin which
just so happens to be a crucial state in
this election
the victim of the shooting has survived
somehow and the details of the incident
remain
unclear that didn't stop the rush to
riot
angry gangs of black and white youth
smashed and burned shops and cars and
attacked policemen in the streets
today we woke to grieve yet again
tweeted biden
elliptically as he called for a full and
transparent investigation
his running mate kamela harris said the
police must be held accountable
neither appealed for calm on the streets
the trouble for biden and harris is the
public perceptions of the black lives
matter movement are souring
george floyd's death in minnesota on
25th of may
sparked tremendous outrage across a
world that was already angry about the
pandemic and the lockdowns
polls suggested huge support for the blm
calls
senior democrats biden included
capitalised by firmly aligning
themselves with the movement
and demanding radical change but it's
been three months now
and the blm riots are ongoing
non-protesters
are becoming increasingly fed up and
receptive to trump's argument that law
and order must now be restored using
fools
one survey found that in the immediate
aftermath of floyd's death
a majority of non-college educated
whites in various swing states said they
supported blm
by the end of july a majority said the
opposite
if biden and harris were more adept
campaigners they would spot that shift
among these once democratic voters who
swung so decisively towards trump in
2016
and would moderate their language
accordingly they would condemn vandalism
and the destruction of often black owned
businesses
as much as they talked about the need to
transform america
they would point out more forcefully
that trump for all his
tough talk has allowed the unrest to
spread
but biden and harris can't switch
signals
especially not on sensitive racial
issues trump however seems to be hogging
the middle ground
his campaign has condemned excessive
police force to the disappointment of
his more hardcore fans
while he tweets aggressively about
stopping the criminality
democrats will take comfort from the
polls even if they are still haunted by
hillary clinton's late collapse in 2016.
biden remains almost eight points ahead
nationally and he continues to lead in
most battleground states
joe is widely considered to be much more
likeable than clinton who lost so
narrowly to trump four years ago
and independents prefer him trump
meanwhile
is approaching the end of his first term
with a lower approval rating than any
post-war president who has won
re-election
that said his approval rating is higher
than george h.w bush's
or jimmy carter's the last two
presidents who failed to be re-elected
trump's efforts to appeal more to black
voters who make up 13
of the u.s population don't appear to
have yet brought much fruit
democrats can hope that the blm story
and the fact that kamala harris's mixed
race will boost african-american turnout
in their favor
yet trump is more popular among whites
than he was four years ago
and whites still make up 60 of the us
population
he's also slightly more popular among
the 18 who are hispanic
it's foolish to make political
predictions especially in such a
tumultuous year
but don't be surprised if in just over
nine weeks
we all find ourselves agreeing that the
greatest trick that donald ever pulled
was to make america elect him again
that was freddie gray now emma burn
within the next year or two
i could go bankrupt my mistake
to join a government-backed affordable
housing scheme and purchase a
one-bedroom flat in east london
for the past four years it has been my
pride and my joy
not to mention my savings my pension and
my financial future
i was grateful for the government's help
in getting a foothold in the city
but now another government policy is
hurtling towards me
against which i have no defense and nor
did potentially tens of thousands of
first-time buyers and the owners of
affordable housing
in my position it might just be the next
big scandal to hit the government
it's all about cladding three years ago
the tragedy at grenfell showed what can
happen when you get this wrong
insulation added for environmental
reasons turned out to be highly
flammable
the residents were living in a death
trap and when a fridge caught fire
the tower block became an inferno
this of course raised the immediate
question how many others are living like
this
and the answer it turns out is all too
many six hundred thousand
including me also we're now told by my
housing association
we've been warned that the cladding
covering our block of flats along with
11
300 other buildings across the uk is
potentially combustible
and it has to be tested should it fail
those tests
the cladding will have to be replaced
and that huge financial cost
is most likely to fall on leaseholders
now you might think this is unfortunate
but is it really a disaster
i mean unexpected expenses are after all
what are the normal pitfalls of home
ownership
in the great monopoly game of life you
pick up a chance card that has you
buying a new boiler
fixing your roof or treating subsidence
is cladding really that different
well the answer is yes first
a good survey can protect you against
repair bills
there was nothing to protect me against
what turned out to be inept government
regulations
which allowed flammable cladding to be
fitted
next is the scale of the cost the new
draft building safety bill
due to be examined by a parliamentary
committee makes clear that leaseholders
will be liable for sums of
up to 78 000 pounds payable within 28
days
other home repairs are affordable this
would be crushing
and all the more so because i'm a shared
ownership tenant
i own a 40 stake in my flat my housing
association owns the rest which i pay
rent on
but i'm liable for the whole repair bill
to put it mildly
i don't have 78 000 pounds or anything
approaching this some
we're not talking about being sent back
to the beginning of my financial life
i'd be sent way backwards it would take
me years of work and savings to pay off
the debt
the government has offered some help but
it's going to fall woefully short
in his march budget rishi sunak
announced a 1 billion first come first
served fund on top of 600 million
already promised for those affected
however
government officials have admitted the
cost will be nearer to 3.5 billion
meaning two-thirds of homeowners will
miss out on assistance
at the same time many housing
associations including moat
one housing group and optivo have
started writing to leaseholders warning
them that
because of charity laws flat owners will
be liable
for remediation work if funding
applications fail
as peter apps deputy editor of inside
housing starkly puts it
we could face the very ugly scenario in
coming months of people who purchase
government-backed affordable housing
products being bankrupted
to cover the costs of removing dangerous
cladding
it's not only the threat of a
devastating cladding bill that keeps me
awake at night
if a building is teamed too unsafe a
waking watch can be ordered
whereby between two and five people walk
around the property day and night
ready to sound the alarm if they see a
fire
although these were only ever meant to
be an interim measure many waking
watches are still
in place after more than a year and
costs are spiraling
at paddington walk a development six
miles away from me
leaseholders have been charged an
astonishing 21
000 per week for a waking watch over a
10-month period
this has all been exacerbated by the
external wall fire review
the ews1 fiasco currently paralyzing
parts of the housing market
again due to cladding the ews one form
was introduced at the end of last year
to give mortgage lenders confidence that
high rises over 18 meters were safe
however in january the government
suddenly changed its fire safety
guidance to include buildings of any
height
even some that don't have cladding
without a form owners of these homes
can't sell
or remortgage the result meltdown
there are only 300 inspectors able to
complete the form
leading it has been warned to waiting
lists of up to 10 years
it's estimated that 3 million people in
private flats are effectively trapped
since i can't sell my home or remortgage
because i don't yet have the form
my property is technically worthless and
there are millions like me wondering
what if anything we can do
will we end up like the students in the
exams marking fiasco
told that we're the victims of a
kafka-esque buriotic
cock-up for whom nothing could be done
i've been told that all this could take
years to finalize
meanwhile life is on hold a generation
of being trapped in their homes
none of us has the kind of money to fix
things
it's hard to overstate the misery this
is causing of the human not just
financial kind
the stories are starting to be told a
couple who can't get divorced because
valuers can't begin to estimate the cost
of fixing their home
a new mum who can't get out of a shared
ownership house because no one will buy
while this mess is unresolved and those
are just the examples people talk openly
about
when they do what strikes you isn't the
anger in their voices it's the utter
despair
suffice to say i'm not surprised by
research by the uk cladding action group
which found that 14
of affected leaseholders have had
suicidal thoughts and eight percent
felt compelled to self-harm affordable
housing schemes were seen as a great
conservative idea
to promote a property owning democracy i
was sold a dream
to work hard get on the property ladder
get ahead i took them at their word and
i now face being
ruined as a result and it's not
something that any of us whose lives
have been plunged into this nightmare
will forget in a hurry
that was emma byrne and finally lara
prendergast
now that we must all wear face masks it
is hardly surprising that they have
started to become a fashion accessory
an israeli jeweler has created a gold
and diamond-encrusted mask
that is said to be worth 1.5 million
dollars
according to the designer the man who
commissioned the extravagant mask which
weighs nearly a hundred times as much as
a typical surgical mask
had two demands that would be completed
by the end of the year
and that it be the most expensive mask
in the world
diamond and crusted face masks may not
yet be everywhere
but floral ones certainly are once you
start spotting them
you will see them all over town normally
covering the faces of women between the
ages of 30
and 50. the dutches of cambridge was
recently photographed wearing a floral
face mask while delivering donations to
a baby bank
her mask came from the british kidswear
label amaya
and was made with a liberty fabric
called wiltshire
i suppose there is a certain irony in
choosing a liberty print to decorate
something
the government has forced us to wear as
part of the war effort
people all around the uk are now
stitching face masks
i ordered one via the website etsy from
a friendly woman in yorkshire who
usually makes chintzy bunting
but has instead turned her hand to mask
making the bunting market presumably
having been hit quite hard by the
pandemic
i went for a retro liberty print option
thinking that the fuchsia pink and
orange design
with its hint of flower power and free
love was a good antidote to our new
reality of endless dollops of hand
sanitizer
and hostile relations with strangers in
the supermarket aisle
it is as cheerful as a mask can be it is
also made of cotton
which means it is easy to bung in the
washing machine
but the problem is and i wonder whether
the duchess of cambridge has faced a
similar issue
the cotton is almost impossible to
breathe through
having used the math just for quick
dashes into the shops for milk bread etc
i only realized this problem when i took
a taxi ride across london last week
in the back of an uber where mass
squaring is also now mandatory i found
myself becoming lightheaded
15 minutes into the journey i started to
feel faint
by the time i arrived at my destination
i thought i might pass out
after thanking the driver he was wearing
a more professional looking mask
one with air vents on either side i
flung open the door as quickly as i
could
and gulped in lungfuls of air stuffing
the mask into my handbag
i vowed not to use it again aside from
perhaps the occasional trip to the
supermarket
i felt foolish for prioritizing
aspiration over respiration
the next day i ordered some of those
hospital green breathable masks
that saw once beloved by tourists
traveling on the london underground
they are certainly easier to breathe
through but they are not nearly as
pretty as my floral mask
that was la prendergast and that's it
for this week
thanks for listening and thanks to max
jeffrey our producer
get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher